تداعيات التقدم الذي احرزته القوات
الاوكرانيه ضد القوات الروسيه لا تزال
مستمره حتى اليوم كمان القوات البريه
الروسيه فقدت المبادره والقدره على احداث
اي اختراقات مهمه في صفوف القوات
الاوكرانيه التي مكنتها المساعدات الغربيه
الكبيره من شن عمليات كبيره في عمق
المواقع الروسيه بل وتحرير مساحات شاسعه
سواء في الشمال او في الجنوب لكن السؤال
لماذا فقد الهجوم البري الروسي زحمه وهل
باتت المبادره فعلا بيد القوات الاوكرانيه
ام اننا امام سحابات تكتيكيه من قبل الجيش
الروسي لمناقشه التحركات البريه لكلا
الطرفين معنا المقدم في جيش الاحتياط
الامريكي والبروفيسور في كليه القياده
والاركان بالجيش الامريكي البروفسر اولا
بروفيسور برايم اهلا بك معنا في
عسكريتاريا هل تفاجئت بتحركات القوات
البريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا
في البدايه نعم بنسبه الي كانت مفاجاه
كبيره لم اتوقع ان يكون تدريبهم وقيادتهم
وصيانه معداتهم ضعيفه الى هذا الحد
انا شخصيا تربيته في الجيش الامريكي في
الفتره التي كان العدو فيها الاتحاد
السوفيتي الذي كان وقتها الخصم الكبير
الشريره المقتدر ولا يزال هذا انطباعي
من ادائهم حتى
يميز الجيش الروسي هو انه جيش يتعلمه
ويبدو انهم يحاولون القيام بذلك الان
نستطيع ان نقول ان القوات الاوكرانيه نجحت
في تطبيق استراتيجيه التقرب غير المباشر
هذا سؤال وجيه اولا اعتقد ان احدا يعرف ما
الذي يجري واقصد بذلك ايام من الصحفيين
والمعلقين المختصين بهذه الحرب فالكثير من
التفاصيل مخفيه خلف باب الحرب وكذلك
لمحاوله الجانبين التلاعب ببيئه المعلومات
فليس واضح ما الذي يجري بالفعل بلا شك
شاهدنا ما يشبه المواجهه غير المباشره في
شهر سبتمبر عندما بدا وكان الجيش
الاوكراني
في منطقه خارج كيف وهذه تبدو وكانها
مواجهه غير مباشر
استخدام المواجهات غير المباشره في البيئه
2014 منذ ان سيطره روسيا على القرن قدم
الولايات المتحده وعدد من الدول الغربيه
تدريب عسكري للقوات الاوكرانيه لكن الان
ومع يعني دخول الحرب على عامها الاول هل
نستطيع ان نقول انه القوات الاوكرانيه
باتت تستوعب العقيده العسكريه الغربيه
وتنجح في تطبيقها على الارض
سيطبقون العقيده العسكريه بالكامل اعتقد
انهم سيجرون عليها التعديلات كما يفعل كل
الجيش
فسيخذون المعدات التي لديهم الوضع الذي
يواجهونه وسيجمعون بين اسلوبهم المعتاد مع
العقيده الجديده
وسيحاولون تطبيقه من الواضح انهم يستخدموا
الاسلحه الغربيه التي حصلوا عليها بفاعليه
ما اثر على عقيدتهم العسكريه يبدو انهم
يستخدمون اطلاق النار الدقيق والمدفعيه
والصواريخ الدقيقه بخلاف استخدام الروس
اطلاقا النيران للتغطيه مناط التاسعه وهذا
احد اكبر الفوارق بين الطرفين ولكنني
اعتقد انك اليه ما يحاول استخدام المدفعيه
لتسهيل او خلق الفرص لمدرعاتهم ومشاتهم
هذا ما يبدو عليه الامر
بانها حرب صواريخ في المقام الاول هل تتفق
مع هذا التوصيف وكذلك على الجانب الاخر من
المستفيد بشكل اكبر هل هي القوات التي
تقوم بالهجوم ام القوات التي تدافع على
الجانب الاخر
سؤال اخر وجيه اكثر مشاهديكم على درايه
بحرب عام
1973 بين مصر واسرائيل التي غالبا اليها
على انها حرب صواريخ بسبب استخدام
الصواريخ المحموله الموجهه المضاده
للدبابات التي يسميها الغرب وهي عباره عن
صاروخ مضاد للدبابات بحجم حقيبه الملابس
وكذلك الصواريخ ارض جو التي كانت كبيره
جدا في عام
1973 وهذه الحرب تبدو مشابها حيث تستخدم
فيها الصواريخ الموجهه المضاده للدبابات
والصواريخ ارض جو المحموله
نوعين من الصواريخ يمنح الافضليه للقوات
التي تدافع في البيئه الحاليه
البصر السيد بالتاكيد القيادات العسكريه
سواء في الولايات المتحده او حتى في الدول
الاوروبيه تراقب تراقب ما يحدث في الميدان
على ارض المعركه ما بين روسيا واوكرانيا
لكن رايك ما هي الدروس المستفاده التي يجب
ان ينتبه اليها القاده العسكريين سواء في
الولايات المتحده او في اوروبا
من اهم الحروب في الخمسين عاما للماضيه
ربما حتى منذ الحرب العالميه الثانيه
برزت منها الكثير من الدروس ان اعود الى
ملاحظه السابقه عندما قلت انه لا احد يعرف
تماما ما الذي يجري حتى هذه اللحظه ولذلك
الدروس سوف تبرز مع مرور الوقت مع ذلك
اعتقد انه هناك خمسه دروس الجميع متاكد
منها اولها ان عمليات القوات المشتركه
الصعبه على اي جيش في اي وقت لذلك عندما
نشاهد تحديات مهمه عبور نهر وهي اصعب
عمليه قوات المشتركه دائما ستبدو قبيحه
للمشاهدين من غير اصحاب الخبره الامر
الثاني هو ان الحل لاي مشكله تقريبا
والعمليات المشتركه بينما يبدو ان الدوره
قدرت غير فعال في عمليه ما السبب هو ان
العمليه المشتركه يجب ان تتم بشكل افضل
وعلى الدبابات ومنظومات الدفاع الجوي مثلا
وجميع القوات العمل معا بشكل افضل ثالثا
اتمنى ان يدرك الجميع ان التلويح بالفضيله
لا يكفي هذه الحرب سميت حرب التلويح
بالفضيله لان العديد من الدول والافراد
يعتقدون ان التعبير الكلابيه عن دعمهم
لطرف ما يحققوا شيئا ولكن ذلك في الحقيقه
لا يكفي للمساعده جهود الحرب درس الرابع
هو ان حرب الكلام او الخطاب حقيقيه فهناك
اهميه كبيره في الكلام الذي سمعناه على
سبيل المثال سابوت فهمك كلام اوكرانيا في
شهر فبراير وفي الوقت نفسه لا اعتقد ان
الغرب يفهم كلام بوتن روسيا في ما يخص
معاناه الاستنزاف والقدره على تحمله
على ان علينا ان نجد طريقه للتفاوض مع
خصنا
اما درس الاخير الذي اتمنى ان يتعلمه
الجميع خاصه القوات الغربيه فهو ان حرب
الاستنزاف تستنزف الموارد لقد اطلقنا
الصواريخ وذخيره اكثر من ما توقعته اي شخص
مثال على ذلك افادت التقارير بان امريكا
منحت نحو ثمانيه الاف الصاروخ جافلين
للاوكرانيين والقاعده الصناعيه الامريكيه
تصنع نحو الف من هذه الصواريخ السنويا
ربما 2000 كحد اقصى وهذين يعني اننا اذا
ما اردنا ان نعوض امام نحن الى اوكرانيا
فسيتطلب ذلك منا بين اربعه وخمسه اعوام
وهذا وقت طويل ولا اعتقد ان دول الغرب
مستعده لحرب استنزاف صناعي بهذا الحجم
اتمنى ان يستفيدوا من تلك الدروس الان
والعديد من الدروس الاخرى لا شك انها
ستبروز مع مرور مين
السيد في كليه القاده والاركان بالجيش
الامريكي شكرا على وجودك معنا